[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Dino here.
In the previous
video in this series,
we learned the basics
of the API portal.
In this video, we will
learn how to publish APIs
to the portal to enable other
developers to find and use
them.
Back to the Apigee
administrative UI.
I can add APIs here.
To add an API, we select from a
list of existing API products.
We created an API product
in the previous video.
This is the thing that
external developers
subscribe to in order to
get keys to use the APIs.
So I'll select that
previous API product.
Now it's asking for a spec.
This is an OpenAPI spec
document that describes
the API being published here.
The document includes
method and URL path pairs.
This spec is the
thing that allows
you to generate interactive
documentation for the API.
You can create that spec
using any tool or even
Apigee Edge itself.
I'll upload my spec here.
Back in the developer portal,
now we see the API product.
Great.
Clicking through, I can
see the API documentation.
The spec we use defines
a very simple API
with a single method/path
pair, get /, a very simple API.
Expanding that, I can
actually try the operation.
Hmm, it's asking for an API key.
As a developer, how
can I get one of those?
To get a key, a developer
needs to sign in.
The portal implements a really
simple email-based sign-in.
Users provide their
email address,
and then a click-through
on the verification
link in the email that gets
sent to them signs them in.
There's no password.
As a developer, once signed
in, I can see my apps.
I can see that I don't have
any, so let me create one.
Name it, provide a description.
Clicking through, I can manage
the products for that app.
Let's turn on access for
that API product and save it,
and then I can see my API key.
Now let's try the interactive
documentation again.
Paste in my API
key, and it works.
Of course, your
API specifications
will be more
complicated than this,
but the documentation will
render nicely for you.
For example, here's what
the API for healthcare.gov
looks like in the
Apigee developer portal.
The portal seems like
a simple website,
but it's more than that.
This is the digital connection
between API consumer developers
and your APIs, a key
part of your API program.
Remember, the Apigee
documentation and the community
are good resources
to learn more.
Until next time,
keep it digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]